welcome back to las vegas now if you
need some help in the kitchen this
holiday carmine's italian and virgil's
real barbecue has you covered for
thanksgiving executive chef michael
engino is here to tell us what's on the
menu because they're stepping out of the
italian and they're stepping out of the
barbecue and they're giving you yams
they're giving you stuffing mashed
potatoes what's what's going on here
yeah so both restaurants are doing their
own style of turkey feast so you got to
come see us at the restaurant or you can
take it home also so virgils is doing
the smoked turkey with cornbread
stuffing uh kind of new orleans style
green beans with some roasted peppers
and tomatoes sweet potatoes with some
marshmallows on top excuse me michael
our intern is here with some utensils
there we go thank you gavin because
you're mentioning all these things and i
need to taste them as you talk about
them okay so continue yeah so you know
fresh cornbread besides the turkey feast
we have the full menu available at
virgil so you can still get yes you can
get the classics and the traditional
stuff ribs briskets mac and cheese not
as good as grandma's hey now
and then also
and then carmine's is doing their feast
also so stuffing mashed potatoes sweet
potatoes homemade cranberries slow
roasted turkey full menu available 45
ounce porterhouse
meatballs
we got plenty of space 800 seats at
carmine's 500 seats at virgil's
entire family so so if you're coming in
to get a package to take home how many
are you feeding uh probably eight to ten
people okay not bad that's a nice small
gathering um and you know if you're if
you're coming into virgils or if you're
coming into carmine's um you guys can
get the traditional menu or you can get
the thanksgiving
feast what else can they do can they be
cocktails is there is there's something
else yeah full wireless available full
whiskey cocktails that i see the wine
over there plenty of wines
old-fashioned we brought some if anybody
wants a drink today
kendall no i'm kidding
okay so what separates
you know your food from you know the
rest in in the area because
when i try your food i've been to i've
been to virgil's
it just tastes like home cooking yeah i
mean we're still scratch kitchen in both
restaurants i mean carmine's is family
style so please bring some french
virgils you know a lot of the portions
are big but they're individual portions
also but for the turkey dinner you know
we asked call ahead reserve your turkey
we're also offering some holiday pies oh
there's dessert you have to have dessert
for for the holidays so what kind of
pies apple pie pumpkin pie of course yep
of course and i know you guys do your
your meat's very special can you can you
talk about one in particular that you
want to describe i mean if i carmine's
just nothing better than the 45-ounce
porterhouse exactly a little bit of
potatoes roasted peppers yeah of course
sausage
and then our brisket we marinate for 24
hours slow cook it 12 to 14 hours
same thing with the ribs marinate
overnight three to four hours uh cook
time and then we can't get our uh
virgil's famous chicken wings oh man and
this is a little cold and it's still
good that means it's good it's good
exactly that means a lot okay so how can
people order if they're ordering the
head yeah call the restaurant um if
you're for in-house the hostess will
take your reservation uh if you want to
order your pie then we'll confirm that
also if you want to order for uh pick up
at the restaurant you call julia at the
restaurant he does catering for for both
restaurants and he'll book you okay and
why did you guys choose to do this for
the community i think a lot of people
need extra help right now right yeah i
mean it's been a rough year so yeah you
know stay home
come to us either way let us let us
cater your needs this way it's much
easier you don't got to clean up exactly
you want put on your own fancy plates at
your house looks like you did it anyway
for people like me
thank you so much michael this looks
delicious